ضربه اسرائيليه بروتينيه في سوريا الهدف
مطار دمشق الدولي القصف اخرج المطار عن
الخدمه مؤقتا واقع قتل بينهم جنديان
سوريان على الاقل
جيش النظام قال انهبل من الصواريخ اطلق من
جهه بحيره طبريا واصابت ايضا اهدافا في
جنوب دمشق اخراج مطار دمشق الدولي عن
الخدمه للمره الثانيه في غضون سته اشهر
ففي يونيو من العام الماضي ان قذف
اسرائيلي الى تعليق كل رحلات لاسبوعين بعد
تضرر المدرج الوحيد العامل اما المدرج
الثاني توقف عن الخدمه جراء قصف اسرائيلي
عام 2021 وفي اواخر العام ذاته قصف الجيش
الاسرائيلي من اللاذقيه الاهداف تشير
بوضوح الى ما تؤكد عليه اسرائيل ضرب
الفصائل المسلحه المواليه لايران وتعطيل
خطوط الامداد لحلفائها في سوريا ولبنان
الضربات الاخيره استهدفت مواقع لحزب الله
اللبناني ومجموعات المواليه لايران داخل
المطار ومحيطه كما طالت مستودع اسلحه وفقا
للمرصد السوري
سيناري يتكرر منذ سنوات تل ابيب تعتبرون
وجود ايران واذرعها على حدودها الشماليه
خطا احمر رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي العائد
نتنياهو يعتبر ايران مساله وجوديه والتصدي
لها على راس اولويه
اولويه وترجيحات امنيه اسرائيليه تشير
ربما الى تحضير لعمل عسكري اسرائيلي
المحتمل في ايران ترجيح يتزامن مع طلب
لوزاره الدفاع بزياده ميزانيتها بنحو
ثلاثه مليارات دولار
ايران تبدو غير مهتمه لتهديدات حكومه
لكنها تؤكد ان ردها سيكون صارما على اي
هجوم غير ان الرسائل العسكريه الاسرائيليه
لا تتوقف بحجمها وتوقيتها حيث
الايرانيون الذكر الثالثه لاغتيال قاسم
سليمان وابو مهدي المهندس بغاره جويه
امريكيه في مطار بغداد